[Music]
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight for the past 14 months
you have heard two main things about the
war in Ukraine the first is that the war
in Ukraine is a war of national
sovereignty it is not a proxy battle
between superpowers Russia invaded
Ukraine that was immoral the United
States supports Ukraine because the
United States supports democracy but the
United States itself is not at war with
Russia this is Ukraine's war to fight
the second thing we have heard over and
over again is that Ukraine is winning
that war Ukrainian troops are brave and
Noble Russian troops are evil and
incompetent the ukrainians are beating
the Russians in the end their Victory is
inevitable
now you're very familiar with these
points because you have heard them every
day since last February you've heard
them repeated by every Power Center in
the United States the Pentagon the White
House the leaders of both parties in
Congress CEOs and celebrities and most
insistently of all you've heard them
from virtually every single Outlet along
the entire spectrum of our national news
media
these are the two essential themes of
the war in Ukraine and both of them are
lies
we know that they're lies because late
last week leaked intelligence about the
war in Ukraine began to appear on social
media briefing slides prepared by the
U.S government began to show up among
other places on Twitter
and the slides show that this is in fact
not Ukraine's war it's our war the
United States is a direct combatant in a
war against Russia as we speak American
soldiers are fighting Russian soldiers
so this is not a regional conflict in
Eastern Europe This is a hot war between
the two primary nuclear superpowers on
Earth
and yet this war has never been formally
declared it has not been authorized by
Congress and for that reason this war is
a violation of American law it is a
crime
the second thing we learned from these
slides is that despite direct U.S
involvement Ukraine is in fact losing
the war
seven ukrainians were being killed for
every Russian Ukrainian air defenses
have been utterly degraded Ukraine is
losing
the Biden Administration is perfectly
aware of this they're panicked about it
but they have lied about this fact to
the public
just two weeks ago for example Secretary
of Defense Lloyd Austin told the U.S
Senate that Russian military power is
quote waning in other words Russia is
losing the war
that was a lie he knew it was when he
said it but he repeated it in
Congressional testimony that is a crime
but Lloyd Austin has not been arrested
for committing that crime instead the
only man who has been taken into custody
or likely ever will be is a 21 year old
Massachusetts Air National Guardsman who
leaked the slides that showed that Lloyd
Austin was lying
he revealed the crimes therefore he's
the criminal that's how Washington Works
telling the truth is the only real Sin
now our news media exists and have
constitutional protection precisely in
order to push back against this
grotesque standard their only job is to
tell the truth and yet tonight the news
media are celebrating the capture of the
kid who told Americans what's actually
happening in Ukraine they are treating
him like Osama Bin Laden maybe a little
worse actually because unlike Al Qaeda
apparently this kid is a racist here's
CNN
The Washington Post as you know reviewed
video of this suspect yelling racial and
anti-semitic slurs is this a dangerous
person this uh air Guardsman who's now
been taken into custody had talked about
being a gun enthusiast had been at gun
ranges he's obviously a member of the
military and he's the big guy in the
scene somehow he has access to this kind
of information and that makes him even
larger a person who thinks they know
better than everyone else they're
smarter than everyone else in their View
and that this is a 21 year old man he's
described as a gun enthusiast
feels like in some of these descriptions
somebody who's maybe hungry for power
so this 21 year old Air National
Guardsman from Massachusetts is not a
whistleblower CNN explains with the help
of the many intelligence agency figures
it is now hired as analysts now he's not
a whistleblower
he's a criminal
because he is unlike the people who run
our government quote hungry for power
and because this 21 year old was so
hungry for power federal law enforcement
had to swing into action with unfamiliar
speed and efficiency and apprehend him
he was that threatening
now keep in mind as a joint we still
don't know where Jeffrey Epstein got
hundreds of millions of dollars we have
no idea nor do we know what he did for a
living we don't know who left pipe bombs
on Capitol Hill on January 6th two of
them
we don't know who leaked the Supreme
Court decision overturning Roe v Wade
we can't even say for certain who killed
the president of the United States
because after 60 years the bite
Administration is still hiding thousands
of pages of classified documents from
the Kennedy assassination
just as they are hiding more than a
billion other classified documents but
tonight we can say for dead certain who
embarrassed Toria Newland and Joe Biden
and that kid is going to jail for a long
long time
that's the standard the media are fine
with that standard watch this remarkable
exchange on Monday of this week between
the White House Press Corps and
bidenflak John Kirby
without confirming the validity of the
documents this is information that has
no business in the public domain it has
no business if you don't mind me saying
on the pages of of uh front pages of
newspapers or on television it is not
intended for public consumption and it
should not be out there
so the fact that U.S soldiers are
fighting Russian soldiers in a war in
Ukraine has no business in the public
domain the fact that the country we are
backing and fighting alongside is losing
not winning
has no business in the public domain you
have no right to know what your
government is doing in your name with
your tax dollars and with the future of
your children and grandchildren you have
no right to know shut up and stop asking
relevant questions okay said the media
and if you want to get really sick to
your stomach go pull a transcript from
the Pentagon briefing today where news
reporters
asked
flax from the Pentagon what are we going
to do to keep information like this
secret in the future not one question
about the substance of the information
we're fighting a war against Russia
directly really don't they have the
largest nuclear Arsenal in the world
not one question how can we help you
keep it secret those were the questions
and not only are the media
not only are the media covering up the
substance of the story which is not who
leaked it but what he leaked
they're covering up the crimes committed
to get you this information the
administration apparently used illegal
surveillance techniques to identify this
kid apparently with the help of the
Washington Post and the New York Times
who are its accomplices they're not
holding government accountable they're
helping government keep you from knowing
what government is doing
today the Washington Post reported it
exclusively obtained some of the
classified documents this leaker
possessed quote the post also reviewed
approximately 300 photos of classified
documents most of which have not been
made public so in the text documents the
leaker is said to have written out
so we've got two problems here if it's
illegal to see these documents if you
don't have a security clearance how is
the Washington Post doing this legally
they don't have a security clearance
well obviously they were given them by
the U.S Intel agencies and are working
alongside them
but the bigger problem is this is
information that's relevant to the
public in a so-called democracy
you can't lie about things that
jeopardize our Collective future and get
away with it and you certainly shouldn't
be doing that with the assistance of the
news media
the news media whose job it is to inform
you of what your government is doing but
instead they are working actively late
into the night to lie to you on behalf
of their masters in permanent Washington
by the way just last week the plan was
to lie in an even more grotesque way and
blame Russia for this and we're quoting
Russia or pro-russian elements are
likely behind the leak of several
classified U.S military documents posted
on social media that offer a partial
month old snapshot of the war in Ukraine
three U.S officials told Reuters on
Friday really who are these officials
who lied to Reuters then Reuters just of
course obediently reprinted their lives
as they always do
news agencies print what they are told
to print by the Intel agencies no matter
how ridiculous it is no matter how much
dignity and self-respect they Exchange
in return for doing it
so what's happening to this leaker now
is what happens to anyone who
contradicts the National Security State
and their obedient servants in the media
you go to prison
so the media can continue to tell you
lies
here's MSNBC for example assuring its
viewers that everything's just fine
what the Russians didn't understand was
that they were going into the lion's den
that kind of of what we would say in the
military
um this Force multiplied made the
Ukrainian Army quite literally
unbeatable they are winning Russia is
going to lose this war every last person
has said exactly what Malcolm just said
they're going to win this award it's not
a matter of if uh but when
14 months in they are simultaneously
telling you that Ukraine's Victory is
inevitable mostly because of the moral
power they possess but at the same time
you need to send tens or hundreds of
billions of dollars more in advanced
weapon systems to Ukraine to keep them
from losing
what will they say now that we know the
truth and that we know that they lied to
us not just the US government but the
U.S news media
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight